bonsoir saison merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france ma visite de joseph
bourrel en russie la semaine dernière
était prévu de longue date un sound
c'est le chef de la diplomatie
européenne qui a choisi la maintenir on
en parlait ensemble la dernière fois
mais le ministre des affaires étrangères
russe sergueï lavrov quel intérêt avait
et il a finalement à maintenir lui cette
rencontre je crois d'abord qu'il a voulu
honorer un rendez-vous qu'il avait pris
avec le représentant d'une institution
importante importante pour le président
poutine importante pour les russes
puisque c'est toujours le premier
partenaire économique de la russie
bien sûr le partenariat avec la chine
monte lentement y compris dans le
domaine économique mais pour le moment
si l'union européenne qui reste le
principal partenaire économique
alors bien sûr monsieur lavrov savez
bien que monsieur borel allait soulever
la question de la faire l'âne avanies
d'abord parce que murray monsieur
monsieur monsieur bord elles
représentent 27 états membres et que les
opinions publiques de ses 27 états
membres avaient été un peu choqué par
l'empoisonnement de la vanille puis par
saha mise en prison
donc il était prévu qu'ils en parlent y
en a parlé bien sûr monsieur lavrov
avait parlé avait préparé une batterie
d'arguments pour disqualifier
l'intervention l'intervention européenne
la vie de l'union européenne sur cette
affaire et monsieur borel et pire il est
resté stoïque devant cette batterie
d'intervention devant cette salve et
finalement il est passé à autre chose et
à dire aux sujets sur lesquels il y à
des coopérations avec la russie qui
pourrait d'ailleurs se développer qu'il
s'agisse de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
qu'il s'agisse de la lutte contre la
pandémie et des problèmes sanitaires en
général qu'il s'agisse aussi des
questions énergétiques et qu'il s'agisse
des questions économiques en général
par conséquent évidemment les
journalistes ensuite n'ont retenu que le
sujet était le plus le plus chaud était
le plus le plus litigieux
c'est à dire la sphère navale
et on n'a parlé que de la sphère navalni
alors justement pourquoi la presse
européenne fustige-t-elle autant joseph
bourrel pour trois raisons la première
raison c'est que josette borel est allé
à moscou en dépit des avis des états
membres qui vise à ne pas y aller
la pologne là les états baltes et il y
est allé sans tenir compte également de
des conseils des américains qui lui
disait de ne pas y aller et des conseils
de l'otan qui visait qu'il ne fallait
pas y aller il a donc passé outre l'avis
des gens qui considèrent que la russie a
pris un cours hostile aux pays
occidentaux et par conséquent il faut
l'isoler et les problèmes d'un avis
contraire en tout cas il est allé voir
sur place ce qu'il en était et puis le
deuxième le deuxième élément de cette
critique c'est que les journaux
occidentaux ont volontiers caricaturer
monsieur morel comme finalement un grand
naïf qui allait se jeter dans la gueule
du loup
c'est à dire qu'ils allaient discuter
avec un diplomate formée à l'époque
soviétique ça a été écrit par beaucoup
de journaux qui en effet a beaucoup
d'expérience et peut parfois jouer au
chat et à la souris avec ses
interlocuteurs
et puis enfin le troisième type de
critique c'est la critique de ceux qui
toujours prédisent l'effondrement union
européenne et qui sont des des thunes
east qui pensent que les états membres
principaux l'union européenne sont en
voie de déclin donc bord elle s'est
trouvée sous la critique conjugué de ces
trois familles de pensée politique si on
peut dire
et effectivement eh bien il doit
aujourd'hui faire face alors que blanche
maison la relation entre l'europe et la
russie dans ce contexte est elle
condamnée à être conflictuelle
certains pays les vrais bien il est
clair qu aux états unis et en chine
on ne souhaite pas un rapprochement
entre l'europe et la russie dans ce
grand jeu quadrangulaire entre les états
unis la chine la russie et l'europe
eh bien il ya là un enjeu considérable
du côté russe
je suis pas sûr que ce soit le cas
puisque vladimir poutine et il ya peu de
temps au mois de janvier
s'exprimant par visioconférence au forum
de davos a expliqué combien la russie et
est européenne et il a dit c'est à
l'europe de jouer mais nous sommes pas
allés beaucoup plus loin avec l'europe
alors du côté européen maintenant du
côté de l'union européenne il ya
effectivement deux camps il ya un conte
qui considèrent que l'europe que l'union
pardon que la russie a pris un autre
cours qu'elle tourne le dos aux valeurs
européennes qu'elle regarde plutôt vers
l'asie et finalement un courant hérité
des néo conservateurs américains qui
considèrent qu'il faut isoler la russie
et qu'il ne faut pas coopérer avec elle
et puis d'autres courants qui au
contraire considèrent qu' il ya beaucoup
d'intérêts communs entre l'europe et la
russie que et que et que de toute
manière un jour où l'eau l'europe et la
russie retrouveront la voie d'une
coopération fondamental parce que c'est
écrire la géographie et dans l'histoire
et puis à peut-être une troisième
catégorie d'ailleurs qui considère que
la france et l'allemagne devraient en
tout cas montré la voie et aller dans le
sens de ces coopérations seiler
peut-être ce qui est en train de se
passer sur leur stream 2 puisque si je
comprends bien madame merkel n'est pas
d'humeur à céder sur ce projet dont elle
considère qu'il est essentiel pour la
transition énergétique de l'allemagne et
de l'europe
donc monsieur morel va faire rapport
comme cet evian votre sujet au conseil
des affaires étrangères de la fin du
mois probablement que les avis
divergeront mais peut-être aussi que
finalement monsieur bord elle proposera
quelques sanctions
personnel contre des russes qui ont des
responsabilités directes personnel dans
le traitement de monsieur navalni soit
lançons un foisonnement soit dans son
jugement serait dans son emprisonnement
mais en tout état de cause la faire sans
les faits évoqués au conseil européen de
mars est comme gelée dit avant-hier il
est très probable que la présidence
française et s'exercera dans l'union
européenne au début de l'année prochaine
au début 2022 proposera d'ici neuf ou
dix mois bien les résultats de dédier
des dialogues qui a été montée pour
trouver comment on pourrait faire
progresser la sécurité en europe et
comment on pourrait rétablir la
confiance en europe
merci claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales